welcome back to the iced coffee hour
this podcast educated guest this time
has made two hundred and three thousand
dollars getting closer two hundred and
thirty three thousand well i got it
pretty much dead on 866. yeah just minus
the three great guess yeah you've made
fifty thousand dollars since i've been
here last night hasn't really hasn't
really been i swear it was one am when i
was here last solid we'll take it where
did the money go jack
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's been three months has it really you
guys wow i'm gonna start a podcast
that's not bad you should man people
love you because we had you on last time
yeah with the video titled something
like the man who owns 100 lamborghinis
for 100 or for 10 million
and you were telling us about your
stories and how you rented out these
super cars to these people and they
would crash them it'd be a huge
liability issue and i know you've been
recently trying to get out of the uh the
car rental the luxury sorry not get out
of it but expand your horizons into
others now i'm the man with 10 million
chickens 10 million chickens
it's funny uh uh daniel mac came up next
to me in my koenigsegg and uh you know
asked me what to do for a living i was
like i just sell chicken now and and he
just it was actually a pretty funny
story but uh he didn't understand it you
know and i thought it was actually
really cool because that means i'm doing
something right you know like when
someone doesn't get what you're doing
then you're doing a good job you know
yeah so renting cars is becoming
oversaturated and like insurance and
just so many little things are becoming
just too much
honestly like it i just don't see a path
how this business exists in five years
so transitioning into
you know chicken was the only way i saw
a way to like continue to monetize my
skill set right and and grow to a level
to where we're international or you know
just national is is good enough but uh
that business you can just drop one
anywhere right like we've got a thousand
plus franchisee applications now
and we're getting um all over the world
right we have like flagstaff arizona
with 73 000 people and we have like the
united kingdom saudi arabia i mean you
just name it people want to put one
there and like when i started to have
the idea to maybe franchise royalty
it was miami la
that's it i believe that yeah you know
it's like there's not really much you
can do with that business now that
business is sexy right everybody wants
not very many people have unlimited
supercar power right i mean that was
kind of one of the things that made me
popular right is the ability to just
drive any car at any time and funny
enough i never drove my rental cars i
always had this weird anxiety that
they'd be like dirty or something you
know which they're not but like i don't
know really it's kind of like
let's talk about the rental car business
first of all how has that industry
evolved how has turo impacted it and why
are insurance rates going up so much why
are we hearing about this auto bubble
well luckily um turo hasn't impacted my
particular business because my
particular price point of cars isn't
really on touro every once in a while
someone throws a lamborghini up there
for like 700 bucks but that doesn't
affect me you know
but it affects everybody else um turo i
think don't hold me to this but they
have been doing like five and 10 million
members right that's not that many
people when you think about a nationwide
amount of members right i mean over 30
million people come to las vegas every
year and rent a car
so
there's a very large number of people
that are renting cars that have no idea
what tourer is you know
but in general the rental car industry
is is becoming oversaturated because of
things like turo because of the price
points right hertz and avis and myself
we know what it takes to rent the car
right the late your next door neighbor
that has three cars on touro has no idea
what it takes to rent a car she knows
what her payment is and she knows how
much she needs to make every month to
make that payment and that's her goal is
to make that payment maybe more to make
her other car payment that she's not
renting right and so that's why touro is
a problem because of people not
understanding the business model behind
running cars right they're just looking
to just kick the can down the road
and this is exactly what happened with
the auto loan bubble that everybody's
talking about right now right it's like
the mortgage crisis in 07.0809
right the only reason someone bought a
car or bought a house was because they
thought someone else would pay more like
didn't matter what it was if they got
approved they'd buy it and so because
the car market was going up so fast
everybody was like i'd buy a g-wagon
because i'm not going to lose money
right if it's 50 over sticker 100 over
sticker they're not going to lose money
because they think that the cars are
going to keep appreciating in value
because of the low production or there's
an issue in you know getting chips and
all these little things it's a lot of
excuses you know i mean if you looked at
ford's inventory i mean they had
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of cars sitting in parking
lots
right waiting for
chips yeah while they're but does it
matter what car it is like let's just
say you're guaranteed to buy a ferrari a
new ferrari at msrp a year from now
would that be a good deal to take over
let's say a lamborghini at msrp versus
like a mclaren at msrp what are your
thoughts a year from now you're
definitely not going to buy a mclaren
msrp because those
the if you're buying one of msrp you're
getting a bad deal
so because they go under msrp very
quickly yeah and even in this
environment manufacturers like aston
martin and mclaren still depreciate it
so sucks to be them yeah um ferraris
always
are we're limited because they make less
than 10 000 cars a year so ferraris did
a really good job of always limiting
their production for two reasons um a
because they don't make um
very uh widely used cars right they make
a very niche car for a very niche person
right so like their mid-engine v8 you
know the current f8 model or the new 296
those are the most widely used cars but
like their gtc for luso and you know the
812 they're very niche and so those cars
always appreciate over time because
ferrari actually sells out majority of
their production line before they really
release the car and so they do that
because well they they want the orders
so that they can get the customers and
maybe the car isn't up to their
standards or it's not
kind of that good people are still
committed to buy it and ferrari buyers
are scared to not buy the next car
because they're they're afraid that they
won't get the car after that right so
it's this kind of mantra that ferrari's
got like their customers wrapped around
their finger which is a good thing so if
you're going to get a ferrari msrp yes
it's great but that ferrari actually
comes with a two-year like no sale
clause so you sign a paper saying you're
not going to sell this to anybody except
the dealer who sold it to you
for two years
and if you do do that and you sell the
car before that to someone else you'll
never be able to buy a ferrari again
because if you buy the ferrari and i'm
the dealer right let's say you paid 300
the car's worth 400
i'm gonna give you 320. and i'm going to
sell it for 400. right and so you make
20 000 bucks which is a minuscule amount
of money in comparison to the value that
you imported for the car so that
particular brand's really unique sure
but like lamborghini
i mean they're making an suv that's
doing a hundred thousand dollars over
sticker you can just go and order one of
those and they don't care if you sell it
the next day right and so that's why the
cars are so increasingly you know
transacted right so they're doing a
really good job of that but that's
changing i mean just in the last two
weeks i mean for instance i purchased an
aston martin dbx which is the suv right
and that car was around 240 000 new this
car had 5 000 miles and it had um
basically some just it like blew a tire
and it like the the fender kind of got
messed up a little bit right i purchased
it for 125 000
and the value of the car when i bought
it was 170 000. i fixed it
and a dealer had offered me 165 000 and
so i agreed to sell time wow within that
two-week period of me fixing the car and
getting all that done by the time i was
able two weeks
the car was worth 140 grand so yesterday
i sold the car for 140 000. in two weeks
it dropped literally over 15 of its
value like that why is that because of
the market going down exactly that's
because you're bubble popped that's the
problem the bubble once the bubble pops
it's like people's mentality changes
right so kind of like similar what's
happening to real estate right now it's
like how low can we get this
right not how much money can we make on
it it's like an opposite approach to
like buying the car so that dealer in
every dealer is lowballing me lowballing
me lowballing me lowballing me saying
you know one guy will offer 140. one guy
will offer 145. one guy will offer 130.
and someone's just going to see who
bites right before it was let's get
closest to the what i can sell the car
so i can get the auxiliary items the
financing and the tire protection and
the dealers would make their money on
the after sale products now they're back
to trying to rip the cars from the
customers because there's an over
abundance of cars available
so that's the the difference in the
bubble yeah where do you think it's
going to end up
i mean that the end is is probably very
close to
becoming the start of the end is
probably very close you know if if if it
starts with one car like the g wagon for
instance was doing 150 000 over sticker
so now dealers are asking 50 000 over
sticker these are for brand new ones if
you have miles on them it's less right
so it dropped 100 000 in a month and
it's going to continue to drop because
the demand like for me and for you
if you knowingly are going to buy a car
that is going to depreciate 50 000
you have to either a really want that
car like it's your dream car for the
rest of your life you're never gonna
sell it
or you have to be kind of like
not that smart
you know and so there isn't that many
customers that fall in the middle of
that yeah right or the people who just
don't care like 50 grand for them is
like a penny yeah but those people
already bought the cars yeah they don't
go out and buy 10 more g wagons like how
many customers don't care
and how many customers can you get to
trade in the g wagon that they bought
last year for the new one that they
don't care about losing money for for
the next one and the next one and the
next one yeah the car is the same
different color maybe so like those
customers that have the six trillion
dollars that was free for our economy
they spent that money
and now that money's gone right so they
paid a million over for a house they
paid a hundred thousand over for a car
now they have all this stuff
right what are they gonna do with it you
know they if they want new stuff they're
gonna sell it cheap right to go get the
other cheap stuff or it's just a
revolving circle yeah but you know what
before we go into that we gotta thank
our sponsor ftx us with the recent falls
in crypto you might be considering
buying the dip and if that's the case i
encourage you guys to try out the exact
same exchange graham and i use on a
daily basis that's ftxus they're one of
the largest us regulated cryptocurrency
exchanges in the world with millions of
users who buy sell track and trade both
crypto and nfts all in one place with
fees that are up to 85 percent lower
than the top competitors all these other
crypto exchanges they tack on hefty fees
on every single transaction yes but with
ftx the fees are minimal so you guys
want to get a good deal hop on ftx with
that link down below plus it's
incredibly easy all you got to do is uh
let me show you jack just select what
you want to buy how much of it you want
to buy and then how often you want to
buy it swipe right and you're done plus
you get free crypto in every single
treaty make over ten dollars they also
allow automatic recurring buys so that
you can dollar cost average into the
markets like we do and between you and i
guys graham can't know this but they're
soon launching ftx stocks so they're
gonna be an all-in-one inclusive finance
app where you can trade stocks nfts
crypto all under one platform it's gonna
be amazing check out ftx with that link
down below in the description again the
link is down below in the description
and now with that said let's get back to
the podcast the big problem is in your
car rental companies when they when they
went and bought everything for auction
value they have to replace those cars
you know so they're gonna they're gonna
devalue the market the most
right because they have you know some of
these companies have a hundred thousand
cars
right
so think about a hundred thousand of the
same model cars going through auction
that just start to drop the value right
right and that's where like the biggest
problem is and what does that mean for
people like you who probably hold
millions of dollars in supercars while
like you mentioned the bubble just
popped and you could have some debt on
these cars
how do you feel towards this whole thing
and how is this affecting your business
personally i've actually made some quite
big adjustments right so i had a bunch
of new allocations that were coming in
like i got two lamborghini urus
uh
three months ago
i didn't even rent them i got them and
sold them right so it's affecting my
business because i'm my inventory is
normally at 30 to 35 cars
now that are plus 200 000 right i mean
my company holds about 70 cars in total
but the ones that are really expensive
it's 35 now i have 16.
that's how it's affecting me because i'm
i'm like running slim because i don't
want to lose the money doesn't that also
go hand in hand with demand aren't we
seeing less demand right now so couldn't
that even out like let's say you have 16
customers now 16 cars works out before
you had 30 customers 30 cars for through
the rental business the demand isn't
really shifted i mean there's less
people in vegas that are doing um
more uh extra activities right so like
we have a helicopter that does a you
know strip tours and that business has
slowed down slightly because
i mean people are coming to vegas i
don't think there's there's probably
some metric out there that says vegas is
the cheapest place in america to drink
right it's like the cheapest alcohol the
cheapest food you know because the
casinos subsidize it right
it's kind of like venezuelan gas you
know how it's like
quarter a gallon right because they they
subsidize it so vegas subsidizes her
hotel rooms it subsidizes your food they
subsidize your alcohol to get you to
gamble right so now we're seeing this
huge influx of people that are not
leaving the casino they're just staying
there to drink party and kind of like
hang out at the pool right so the
tourism numbers are
are really kind of changing and their
values are going up but the people who
are coming in are not spending money
right so that's why
you know companies like um the venetian
i don't know you're not really on the
strip too often no but like the win has
like 30 rolls-royce phantoms and in
front of my office is like their way to
get to the airport i used to see like 15
to 20 a day
i haven't seen one in a week you know
those people are not coming to vegas
anymore so the demand is is slowing down
for for like these wealthy crazy people
right but the people who don't have a
lot of money are coming and they're
spending money on credit cards you know
they're renting the slingshots that i
have i see those everywhere yeah so like
the demand shifted
right so like the supercars like you're
saying jack is it's it's different
right but for the like the auto cycle
product which is you know decent margins
it's pretty good it's increased
so like
we just are like in the car market the
bubble shifting the demand right now
you're gonna see the demand go towards
the like the low income for instance you
have a guy that
shouldn't be driving a bmw is now going
to probably lose his bmw because his
payment's 11. the average car payment's
like 700 i saw that like just recently
yeah
i'm just looking at my financial ability
yeah right and and everybody around me
like my sister right she makes like 75
000 a year
her car payment is 400
and she's like not having a hard time
but she's not having like this over
abundance of savings to like live off of
right imagine if her car being was seven
hundred dollars like for a mazda you
know how could they survive right so all
these people that have the above average
car payments i mean if an average car is
700 what is an ice car
12
like jack can you have a 1200 car
payment
uh
i mean like of course you can
survive would that make sense jack
probably has thought about that let's be
real here jack has looked at teslas and
been like it's not that bad 1500 a month
well teslas were like 700. so tesla was
my mom has a tesla lease and it's 719 a
month for a model s 2020 right the base
one that's what my mom drives
you know but she contributes part of
that car payment to her fuel right so
like the excess fuel that she would
spend you know maybe it's 50 a week
that's 200 that she credits in her mind
towards that car payment so her old car
payment may have been 600 and she'll get
a tesla with 800 she breaks even she
gets a more reliable car yeah you know a
better driving experience you know and
and something along those lines right
but now a tesla's 1500
the same car i mean it would scare me to
have a seven hundred dollar a month car
payment i would hate that what about a
fifteen hundred dollar one what about
two thousand jack i would hate a little
bit more
yeah
i mean those are real numbers now those
are normal numbers are people qualifying
for this though because i know with
mortgages it needs to be 33 of your
income so what's the metric for cars
funny story all right i know a guy who
he makes two million dollars a year on
salary he owns a he paid for a 700 000
house
and um he he paid cash for it he went to
take out a mortgage on his property to
cash out refi at 2.7 something percent
back a couple months ago it took him
four
months
okay he's an orthopedic surgeon four
months to do a cash out refi he took 300
grand out okay
the following month he has a few
lamborghinis as well all paid for the
bank offered him um a refinance on his
car
he got a 300 000
car loan
on a car they did not even look at they
did not even inspect they walked into
the bank and in nine minutes they took
the title and gave him a three hundred
thousand dollar check but couldn't they
see that this guy has a ton of assets he
has plenty of evidence
four months for the same amount of money
right that's why the auto loan industry
is terrible because they don't do any
due diligence yeah they could literally
write you the same exact you could take
an asset that's worth a million dollars
pull 300 grand on it right for a house
and take you four months to go through
the world of questions but walk in and
get a car loan and take out 100 of the
value of the car for 300 grand
at the same interest rate or just
slightly more in 10 minutes right so
like that's the problem with the auto
loan industry is they don't check
right that's how it wasn't 07. they
didn't check you just buy a house is
that because of regulation
that's because that's how the banking
system is designed currently i think for
auto loans uh when i was talking to
lucky he said there's no oversight or
there's no one
uh you know company or one industry or
one one
you know entity to look over these loans
to ensure that they're accurate they
don't sell up to the banks
to have that due diligence but a lot of
them just will stamp it off sell it off
yeah well they're not selling them to
government entities yeah that's the
problem right so like fannie mae freddie
mac you know they're buying all these
homes and they're buying all these
mortgages and putting them on the stock
market and stuff i don't know if they
don't do the same thing
when did you sell your excess 20 cars
of your inventory over the past six
months
because i saw the market coming down
when you were selling them and also when
you were holding cars all through the
appreciation of the car market were you
when you eventually did sell them were
you selling them for a profit and then
what about when you recently sold this
last you know 520. with the exception of
the most recent aston martin that i just
told you about like last week every car
sold at a profit right that's why i sold
them because i knew that i couldn't make
as much money like i could make more
money in that one hour selling the car
to someone who was willing to pay for it
than i could renting the car six months
right so that's what i looked at i was
like well why would i rent this for six
months take a gamble you know on on this
uh it's it's wild but are there going to
be any cars that hold their value
because you still bought a car that was
how much five million dollars i have a
couple of multi-million dollar cars um i
just bought a package
yeah you have a pagani i was gonna drive
her today but oh what did you drive
today i i i just drove uh okay so funny
story tell me it's a vulva 2006 no
2022 ford bronco okay yeah sure i was
yesterday
what do you mean half the key well the
other half's in the car because like it
has a little thing no
so
i was gonna drive that today gosh look
at that but uh
the yesterday i took off to go check on
a restaurant of mine yeah in summerlin
and i had to take some stuff there i had
a light fixture right and so i needed to
drop the light fixture off the
electrician to install it so we have
this like ford bronco that i bought two
of them for the rental fleet to like
build them and make them all cool and
crazy
and uh i left my office keys
in the in the office and then i didn't
get back in time and my employees locked
it so my office keys are in the office
and our podcast happened to be before my
office opened and so i had the key to my
car in my pocket
so they couldn't move it out for me
so i took the bronco
so i would have loved to have seen that
yeah that's okay i noticed
first of all how much is a pagani so
this car is worth uh just under like
like around three three two three one
it's it's worth what you played for 300
000
yeah talking like yeah so this this car
if pagani was 300 grand i would have one
yeah
all of them
the thing with the paganis is that
there's only 100 made right so i have a
coupe the going doors and there has only
been four sold within the last few years
so the value of a pagani is kind of
undetermined at this point right there
is one listed right now it's a bc which
means it's like a race car version for
five million so mine's on a bc mine's
actually car number 50 out of 100 i got
a cool number
so um i think that my car's worth
like what i paid for it and what it's
worth i think i have like a million and
a half equity okay hey sorry don't want
to interrupt but first we want to thank
our sponsor wealthfront graham you
wouldn't believe it man i found a two
dollar bill on the street and i don't
know what to do with it should i hang it
up on a wall yeah no if you want to lose
money to inflation you could do that or
you could put it with our sponsor
wealthfront wealthfront is a saving and
investing app that can help you earn
more on your money and start building
wealth for your future if you're keeping
your cash anywhere that isn't earning
you a high interest rate you should
really reconsider that's because the
wealthfront cash account gives everyone
a 1.4
apy interest rate which is 20 times what
traditional banks pay and unlike other
savings options you'll always have
access to your money since they have
unlimited free transfers no account fees
and free access to over 19 000 atms
wealthfront only takes a few minutes to
sign up and you can start earning your
1.4 apy immediately and if you start now
you'll get a free 50 bonus with a 500
deposit it's literally a free 50 bonus
you guys should definitely check it out
there are already nearly a half a
million people using wealthfront to save
more earn more and build long-term
wealth so why wait earn 1.4 percent in
your cash today by visiting
wealthfront.com ich to get started
that's wealthfront.com
ich this no-brainer good news has been a
paid endorsement from wealthfront so
thank you thank you so much well front
and back back to the podcast what about
values for these cars are you worried
about this car going down or like well
he's high-end the reason so like my
koenig said right you know those that's
like a four and a half million dollar
car now you have a koenigsegg well i
know you have a koenigsegg but i know
it's four and a half million yeah both
of them at the same time i have yeah i
have a lot of those cars right now yeah
uh
because you're not renting you're not
renting them out no why keep the money
in those cars because it's better than
houses
a they're more liquid right and they
they have no value there's no comps
right so like my koenigsegg for instance
is a aguero s so i have the only road
legal aguera in the united states
there's only one
so there's eight aguera rs's which are
like race cars that are very
i don't i don't want to say the word
like uncomfortable because that's like a
kind of a slap in the face for a
koenigsegg but they're like very
difficult to use
my friend there's one here in town my
friend has on aguero rs and i drove it
around the block compared to mine and
i'd probably almost pay more for mine
because it's more usable than his right
and i think he feels the same way too
i'm not exactly sure i don't know but
like that car is almost unusable and
those cars are upwards of 10 million
dollars so i have the only car that's
road legal right and um
i feel like mine's worth like five like
half of that because it's not as cool
like as like fancy right but it's still
the same car same engine but you pay
less for these how are you able to pay
less and come in with instant equity
wouldn't the guy be for you to say i'm
the only one gotta pay me well i bought
it a long time ago yeah you know before
this this transition into like because
think about like a few years ago there
wasn't that many cars that cost this
much money
and now every new car right like the new
koenigsegg the jessico
it's like four million dollars like base
price
right so that pulls the value of mine
way up you know so it's um
it's just the way that it works right
like the ferrari like the four five
eight italia right they used to be 140
000 and now they're like 240 000 because
the base price of ferraris went up right
so when the value of the car goes up
like like your car was 140 000 new right
and it's worth 400 000 today right so
the new ford gt being 1 million dollars
brings your car up and so the cars that
i have the new ones are so much more
expensive
that it's more attractive to buy the
older ones right and that's what happens
you know so if the new ford broncos
right like the next year the base price
went up twenty thousand dollars it would
bring the value of my previous year one
up you know at least half
so that's what's happening with the car
world today is mercedes announced that
they were going to drop all of their
crappy cars right like their a-class
their b-class are they really yeah they
decided to like just not make those
anymore and raise the price because a
they don't want to sell to people who
are
faking it because they're complicated
and they're they complain a lot they
bring all their cars in for warranty
work all the time because they can't
afford it and when they get the cars
back on lease the people that have those
lower tier cars don't maintain them
properly right because they like i said
they can't afford it right and mercedes
service is the same size terribly
expensive yeah for e-class c class
whatever class you have they're all the
same
right you know the service the spark
plugs they all use the same stuff so
people in the lower tier cars aren't
maintaining them they're trashing them
and so the dealers are getting these
cars back that they have to put you know
10 20 of the purchase price back into
reconditioning and then try to resell
them again and to another person to have
the same revolving circle versus just
selling one s class instead of like 11 c
classes you know they make the same
amount of money right and so that's
what's happening into the car world then
the next like mercedes g wagons they
raise the base price by 40 000 for 2022.
let's talk about the chicken now yeah um
how did this idea come to light
how do you start this off
well i'm kind of like one of those guys
that that knows that the end is near you
know all the time i mean what comes what
goes up must come down
and um you know i had such a great run
with the car rental business uh i
started in 2015 and uh by 2020 i was
like kind of like it was surreal you
know we were just it was just printing
money it was so good
um but then
i mean in reality
it just it's gonna change right and so i
didn't want to be
thinking about what i do next when the
other one was over so i sat down and
actually was it was about the time that
uh the election was happening in late
2019 and i was like wow you know the
world is going to change the economy is
going to change you know we're going to
have a different party take over
everything is going to shift right so
let's prepare for that now so my best
friend edmund he
he always like wanted to get me to
invest in this other chicken company and
i went out there and i tried it and i
was like yeah it's cool i'm just i'm not
like a big proponent of doing things
with other people right because then
the control factor is kind of unique
right so i said i mean let's just do it
on our own right everybody's got
nashville hot chicken right why don't we
make something else let's make like
texas hot chicken we'll leverage my name
houston we'll call it texas hot chicken
right and and we'll create a sweeter
version that's more mass marketable
because like nashville hot chicken is
very it's very aggressive it's it's
designed to like hurt your mouth it's
very spicy like even in the mild and
mediums and stuff like their flavor
palette is very aggressive so it's got a
lot of middle eastern spices in there
like cumin and other different things
that are not very well rounded for
america and it was very popular in la
but la has a very diverse community of
people right so it worked really well
it's funny in nashville hot chicken got
very popular in los angeles yep i could
see it yeah and i mean you lived in los
angeles but if you go to la there's like
probably 300 200 some crazy number of
different businesses that sell nashville
chicken so when edmond and i sat down we
discussed it uh we created this recipe
that was a little bit better
than
nashville because it was like i said
more you know uh even kill and i think
that
that's the reason why
we became so popular so fast is because
we we made a product that was like sweet
you know it's spicy you can get really
spicy ones i mean you guys have all had
it here on the podcast i mean it could
work incredibly yeah i mean that's not
designed to be edible it's designed to
be like almost like a gimmick right you
know anybody that eats houston's
we have a problem is just
i've never even i couldn't even touch it
right i've only had a mild i've never
even had a medium sandwich at my
restaurant really you should i just we
should have brought one and just had to
eat it yeah well i just have like this
ulcer and like maybe i'll just like puke
blood and hence the iv business i'm just
trying to get healthy you know sure i'm
like super fat now you know so started
this chicken business i was like 170
pounds in 2019 yeah now i'm 203 okay
like that's a lot of weight right but it
tells you how good my food is right so i
keep eating it right which is wonderful
but uh yeah i got to go i got i told all
my employees don't serve me anything but
a salad no matter what i order yeah okay
just if i order a really crazy sandwich
bring me a salad yeah houston is a great
setup too i went to his house the other
day or i guess it was a few weeks ago
he's a private chef yeah cooking like
making pokey like fresh what a fresh
poke bowl yeah i walked in is like do
you want pokemon like what
he's like no you're making it right now
like literally
yes and it was amazing
how much does a private chef cost uh
less than it cost to go out to eat every
night
so for a family of four there yeah
that's when i give him five grand a
month um covers all my stuff guys let's
just uh let's just split it let's just
go three ways let's go five i bet we
could if we all went in the same amount
between four people that would be
you know with macy 1200 1250
yeah that would be about a thousand a
month
it's 30 a day that's not bad that's not
bad because nobody uh in my household
likes cooking so yeah well what's good
about the the chef is that they um so
he makes i don't eat uh i don't eat
anything comes out of a microwave i
never have i figured like that's where
cancer was invented you know cancer and
microwave came out at the same time so
i've i've always thought that in my life
it's probably wrong but it doesn't
matter so anyways
um i don't reheat any food so he
i eat my lunch uh out um with my my team
in my office or whatever but when he
comes over and cooks he actually makes
enough food for my kids and my wife for
the next day so like they get their
lunches and uh if they want breakfast
like he puts a whole menu together for
him so my kids are homeschooled so they
their teacher comes over and she reheats
the food in like the stove and
everything it has the whole kitchen for
yeah and so that 5000 doesn't just
include dinners it's pretty much all the
meals that we eat as a family
so yeah yeah it's pretty dope yeah side
uh tangent here is there a reason you
chose homeschooling versus like a public
school or a private school uh yeah why
because they're like not safe
so it's a safety thing yeah i mean also
like
mentally and physically both are not
safe you know you can't control
like your kids are taught what the
teachers know right so like if i wanted
my kids to be taught by somebody i would
want them to be taught by someone who i
look up to or i trust that is giving
them the right kind of knowledge i mean
i think that the next generation like my
kids are
three and six
and there's just no reason that the the
teachers that are in i'm trying to be
not rude right now so i gotta i'm just
gonna yeah
right yeah okay the teachers that are
currently teaching their skill set and
their knowledge is based on the past and
our our world is changing so fast they
don't have time to adapt right so like
let's just say for instance on youtube
right right now if you want to get into
a business right you're going to learn
from people like ryan you alex from
aussie these these like business
influencers who've had a very long track
record of being successful
right so
if i want my kids to learn something you
know now basic skills like reading and
writing is simple stuff okay i'm not
concerned about that but like the the
basic rules and principles and morals
that they're going to live by i want
them to learn that from someone who i
look up to or i trust right and so i
hired a very specific teacher to teach
them those things you know and plus
school kind of
gears kids towards working nine to five
right i mean you go to school from x
amount of time to x amount of time and
you have homework and like there's just
so much structure there and in the
future 20 years from now when they're
going to be on their own i don't think
that that structure is going to exist
anymore
what about the social aspect of them
getting to hang out with other kids and
you know trying to figure out where they
fit in and networking and all those
those skills that are kind of learned at
a younger age everybody says that yeah
and then i ask them like like
when have you ever seen kids playing
anymore they're all on their phones
none of them go out after school like
when we were kids we used to go on the
front of the house and just skateboard
and hang out and ride bikes yeah you can
go into any neighborhood and you'll
never see that now right there is no
social aspect of school it's actually
antisocial like all the kids are getting
bullied online while they're at school
you know and it's like this whole new
like front you know and that's like the
worst part about school is being around
other kids you know because everybody
has their own demons now and now that
there's so much information like even
there's there's an actual number there's
a real statistic for suicide among girls
under 14.
like if you would have asked me that
if that was even possible i would have
said no way but now there's a real
number for that because of like
a peer pressure and of all this like
crazy science stuff that they're they're
going through you know in the in their
hormones and all this stuff and during
that age right i don't want them around
those types of people because the other
parents may be neglecting their children
at that time and those kids are taking
it out on my you know children you know
like i don't know if my kids are hanging
out with the right people when they're
at school i don't know what they're
doing you know what about when they're
like 20 and they're going off on their
own do you think that maybe they might
not be as prepared as someone else who's
had those experiences i don't i don't
know because we don't know what the
future holds but like my kids go to
gymnastics right i mean i have uh four
or five employees that all have kids
about the same age and every week you
know they do a play date like you see my
house i have a playground and there's a
kids environment there right so they
have their friends over two three days a
week they play there's a couple cousins
that we have you know that are all the
same age so they're getting a lot of
time with other kids but just not a
massive amount of kids right they're
getting a lot of time with specific kids
that i think are all being raised in the
right the right setting sure you know so
i don't know i'm really specific with
that stuff like yeah i feel like the 15
years that i was in school or whatever
that is 14 years
was the worst part of my life and all
the bad decisions came from people that
i knew whether i was trying to be cool
like them or i was trying to lead them
or whatever it was all those choices
were all from that environment right and
when i started to be on my own when i
when i turned 18 and i moved out and i
did all this stuff my life started to
just go straight up and i was very
focused and i was independent and i
choose i chose my own friends right and
i had two or three not 30 right so it
was a really different
i don't know i'm just like maybe i'm
really weird you know
it's a tough conversation it's easy for
me to say without kids site tangent back
to back to chicken now
um i know yeah you got it you gotta say
yeah this is we okay we got an exciting
new opportunity here uh i'm actually
really looking forward to this so
you held a car meet
at a grand opening of a restaurant which
i do all the time all of them at uh
houston's hot chicken and i show up
there and we go in and the food was so
unbelievably good and the staff was so
incredibly friendly and then you came up
and thanked us all for coming and and i
think i jokingly said oh i want to see
the back or like because you guys were
so busy back there yeah and you gave me
and macy the tour of the back and it was
like this it looked like a you know the
uh the really high-end lab from breaking
bad at the very end like it kind of
looks like that with like all the the
stuff no but seriously
no wonder that chicken is so addictive
but yeah but it looked it reminded me of
just like just how pristine everything
was and like how nice they kept it and
uh i jokingly said like oh man i want
one of these or like i and you said yes
and so for the last few weeks we've been
working on some of the some of the
contract details but i think we're
pretty close on signing to get can i say
the location sure sahara and jones here
in las vegas
uh and that would be the building
and so and it has a drive-through which
i'm really excited are you using the
drive through we're not using the
drive-through anymore because i've
changed i've i've
oh i was sticking i was looking forward
to driving all right i'm just learning
about this is such a bad idea and i've
been saying this for a long time because
no one sees the end result of the
drive-through okay with the
drive-through you cannot serve alcohol
right with a drive-through you have to
have six extra staff members and with
the drive-through people drive around
the building and don't get the full
experience right so they're not seeing
the inside that you saw they're not
feeling the inside right
and they actually order less per ticket
than if they go inside and so the
drive-through increases your revenue but
decreases your profit and so
i had this argument with my business
partner edmund and we agreed to try it
and so i finally got it through
everybody's head that the drive-through
is a bad idea because alcohol
pairs so well with our food and
it's got
the biggest profit margin on anything we
sell in the restaurant
so if you want to make money and you
want to differentiate differentiate
yourself from chick-fil-a
the
my biggest pet peeve is someone
comparing my restaurant to chick-fil-a
right we're not even close i mean that's
like literally comparing your volvo to
my pagani
which i tried to do yeah
it's offensive you know i don't get
offended easily but we both have leather
seats it's kind of cool
but we both have windows
yeah yeah but it's it's the
drive-through is such a bad idea because
we're not building a brand to be
considered cheap right we're building a
luxury chicken brand right that's what
we want to be that's what you want to be
because in the luxury space right the
sky's the limit you know you're bringing
in someone that's like ready to spend 30
40 dollars for their meal get a drink a
beer a 20 ounce draft beer right we have
draft beer
craft regular modelo you know we have
our own beer now hht called afterburner
and um it's it's like designed to be
that place where you want to hang out
you know like the above
it it like
i think we're gonna replace the
restaurants like applebee's okay right
applebee's outback chili's those
restaurants to me are dying right
margins are too low
the buildings are too big and these fine
casual chipotle-esque restaurants are
going to replace those big box waiter
you know uh sit down tables
because that experience is not they're
not able to compete right when i can
serve a chicken sandwich that is miles
ahead of that food right i mean chipotle
sorry naturally uh chili's and
applebee's are serving frozen food
everything's frozen nothing's fresh
right and they have huge staff numbers
that cost a lot of money and so like
that
genre is going to get replaced and i
want to be the one that replaces them
and so that type of food isn't fast food
right but it isn't like fleming's or
high-end food like catch or something
that you go into like a full crazy you
know 100 meal for right and so when we
put alcohol there we make way more money
how do you have your employees so
friendly and happy all the time because
i pay them well can you share some of
those numbers or like how you look
basically there's 25
the average restaurant is 25 people
right everybody gets a tip share so the
average restaurant brings in 22 to 28
000 a month in tips
so between 25 people they all split that
so everybody's getting like a thousand
dollar bonus at the end of the month
and um we're hiring baseline experience
so you know people make 13 an hour
people make 15 an hour no one makes
minimum wage i mean our lowest paid
employee is 13 which is five dollars
above minimum wage here in vegas
um
but it's the culture
right like when you walk into royalty
and you really haven't been to royalty
too often but when you walk in there
like it's the vibe people love that
that's why i'm so picky about people
going inside the restaurant because
that's what you're missing no one
expects that kind of environment when
they walk in
like
you're asking about people that are
friendly from four months ago that you
remember yeah you remember the people
that served you four months ago that
should be like right there to tell you
that the experience of going in is worth
every every minute that it takes for you
to get out of your car and go order
inside right you know that's the goal
for the restaurants for people to feel
like to always exceed expectations right
so that's our company culture you know i
mean there's all these business guys
that ask you what your values and your
principles are and
houston's hot chicken is the principle
is to exceed your expectations but it's
the culture around the employees and
it's that experience that that customers
get when they walk in but how do you
pick that and how do you ensure that
they that they keep up to that standard
the easiest way to continue your culture
is to make sure your leadership has that
culture right because people follow the
leader okay like if the leader has a bad
attitude and he's over there yelling at
everybody your culture just dies
immediately right but if you have this
guy that's always so happy it's
contagious right and if you see the
manager of the restaurant going out and
cleaning the tables and taking care of
the customers and you know remembering
people's names
right we have people to eat at houston's
chicken three times a week you've gotta
remember their order you gotta remember
their names you gotta you gotta really
treat them like they're special right
and so if you if you have that from the
top it just
just trickles all the way down another
thing that uh you were mentioning you
want to talk to alex hormozy
yeah i just up with this i i've been i
watched actually alex uh for about a
maybe a year now and um
i just i think that alex and i have a
lot of things in common and i think alex
and i have a lot of things that we don't
agree on and i've i know alex lives in
vegas and i think it'd be cool to do
honestly i just i feel like your podcast
needs drama you know i mean your best
video like was jack in his dating life
right people loved that jack yeah come
on for the algorithm we want to bring
back another tinder date and just
but you got to think of the algorithm
i like it man i really don't like you
don't like it anything dating like
anything like that like airing it all
out online i'm just not been
the highest population we get the
highest so popular because everybody
wants to know the drama yeah but the
thing is there's external
like things that occur outside of
whatever happens in the podcast
it's embarrassing
but then i leave the podcast room and i
go back home and then i get a few dms or
whatever i get a few texts from my
family that's watching it and it's like
oh my god what do they say give us some
examples it's just weird man my grandma
watches every episode
so i don't know what's wrong with that
you grant me let's say let's say there's
like a a girl i went on one date with
right and then i talk about an
experience that i had with some other
girl that i went on a date with then
it's like well what is this one girl
that i went on a date with
think now that she's seen me talk about
a date that i had with this other she's
jealous
i don't get it if you went on a date a
year ago i'm not talking about dates a
year ago man eventually it'll be let's
say yeah eventually it'll be a year ago
so we'll just start talking about dates
that are so like
jack you have to postpone your love life
for one year basically but what's the
downside if we have one tinder date on
now
i just think what happens first of all i
think people are going to get sick of it
second of all i don't think so second of
all
like stuff that happens like i said
outside the podcast the thing is we
finished wrapping up the episode you go
home and you go you know kiss macy or
whatever you guys do in a secret okay
alex does the same with his wife or his
fiancee wife kelsey right and then i go
and then i have like
all these random awkward situations that
happen outside of this because i tied
myself just maybe they would
want to be like i feel like some girls
are such attention grabbers that they
would want to go on dates with you just
so they can end up on the podcast that
sounds terrible i don't want that like
jack here's the thing man i think what
jack's worried about is that we're going
to film an episode and sometimes we post
like um a month later sure so maybe in
that month he starts seeing someone new
that's not what i mean about it
but what's the problem what i'm worried
about
so when we did that thing where i went
on a date with those four girls right
let's say that there were let's say two
three girls i was casually talking to
right maybe we hadn't even gone on a
date yet right but i met him on some
tinder thing or whatever or maybe i'd
gone on one date with them we just went
out and got lunch or dinner or whatever
right and then they see this video where
i blind date four girls on the sta
family graham stefan aft sorry graham
stefan after ours i do that right um
then what right they they see i don't
see that you're casually dating it's not
and if they think you're they're your
girlfriend after i know but the thing is
i think
although we are capturing
casually
that they haven't even met
like you were saying like maybe just
talking to you online on tinder and if
they see the video but you haven't even
met okay well i think we have to define
dating dating is literally just going on
a date with someone yeah you have no
obligation to that person whatsoever but
the thing is that's not necessarily
stuff that you want them to be privy of
you don't want to air all that stuff out
but how do they even look for it
but they know who i am oh they do
but you don't want them to be on the
podcast
i'd say it's pretty hard at this point
not to define me at least somewhat by my
work right it's like if i talk to
someone this is going to come up
inevitably so they're going to look up
they're going to just try it one more
time i don't see the issue jack yeah
because you know you're already you have
a fiance already just just go like this
for a second
dude me just
yeah you should just bring a blind date
on the podcast and not tell them i've
been thinking that you should you should
really do that be so funny be like hey
who's our podcast guest it's your new
blind date all right you know
all right jack you're good
cool that wasn't even that bad all right
i just didn't you know okay surprise
yeah i agree
surprise
all right so yeah alex uh
you know he's so he's so uh he's very
just like me very specific in his his
views right and i think that that'd be a
cool conversation to have i don't know i
just think that there should be some
drama on this podcast you know besides
jack's love life right you should just
get a couple of guys on here that just
don't have the same opinions on some
stuff and just have them debate it out
you know i love that i think it's a
great idea i was on ryan's podcast and
we were talking about the real estate
market a little bit and like i don't see
how it's sustainable that someone bought
a house in 2020 for 700 grand and posted
it in 2022 for sale for 2.7 million you
know and he said there's not there's no
crash coming and i'm like well i don't
really see how that's sustainable so you
know we had like a little uh mild
argument about that
and he gave his opinion and everything
and i even actually went back and
watched it myself you know i was
interested to like hear his side of the
story without me having to think of my
rebuttal in that side of the story you
know so um i think the debates between
these big entrepreneurs i mean there's
so many people online now that tell you
how to get rich and how to be successful
and a very small amount of them have an
actual track record of running
businesses outside of the business of
telling people how to get rich right you
know so like i think instagram and all
these places is oversaturated with with
the gurus right that have never done
anything with their life other than
be a guru you know and so i think alex
is the first guy that's like had a long
track record of business and he's doing
it for the right reasons you know he's
putting all that content that is uh
very very important i mean his wife is
incredibly intelligent which is super
cool you know and so i don't know i just
think that'd be a good a good thing i
mean what do you think i really want to
do that i love the idea i think we
should definitely host a debate yeah
yeah that'll be the first ever iced
coffee hour debate but yeah i just think
it'd be a really cool
like update or upgrade to the ice coffee
hour yeah you know i mean i agree how
many people how many more people do you
plan i mean how many more people can you
put on here i mean you've literally
interviewed everybody no hillary mark
cuban
i mean i feel like we've
we've hit maybe ten percent of the
potential
yeah yeah but you guys are like you're
hitting a lot of the youtube guys right
so if you want to branch out into the
real business world and you get like
gary vernon chuck and you know the big
big guys right i think those would do
excellent you know um but that's a
that's a different level right that's
like a different stage of the podcast
you know that's when
you don't do the youtube cuz anymore you
know because those are the that's the
bottom tier right and though they're the
next tier but as far as like youtube
guys i mean i've watched almost every
podcast you know and um i guess i'm just
trying to i i'm trying to figure out who
i'm missing you know but there's a lot
of people that are new and upcoming yeah
you know um i think you should actually
interview some like local like celebrity
type people too
maybe like um we really want to do dan
balzarian yeah he would never come on
here no he's
terrible i i dan's here i mean he's just
maybe i mean dan's about to be on
dancing with the stars kind of lifestyle
you know like i feel like he's a fall
from grace at this point you know what i
mean he's like really falling off but
that's just basically because he doesn't
care you know just watch he watches the
pod be like i'll debate houston oh yeah
i actually lived in dan balzerian's
ex-house
so
he lived in this house and i moved into
it and it how like the guy that had
bought it i rented it for like eight
months because i wasn't in transition
and um i don't know it just felt weird
did you see anything in that house that
like screamed dan it was all the same
stuff he left it furnished it was his i
had to replace the beds right for the
eight months i lived there i bought any
beds but all of his furniture's still
there all of his stuff is still there
every single thing was it like fancy
stuff yeah yeah it's got some excessive
tape
taste no i mean i was renting it so it
was the owners the owner probably just
took the furniture or made like a buy
out i don't know i think like shin lim
the magician totally he's cool you know
like he he'd be a great person because
he's like i agree just a cool come-up
story yeah i mean there's a lot of guys
like that in vegas that have like a cool
kind of story i mean andre um he's he's
kind of like that right i mean like las
vegas local was like some fame and
everything yeah and he did some cool
stuff i don't know yeah we've had andre
on what three times twice twice under
school i like andre yeah i met andre
like i think five or six years ago no
when he first started yeah wow we had a
mutual friend it was like a roommate at
the time okay um he was one of my
employees and andre had moved in with
him they started living together and um
he'd come around and show me all those
card tricks and i was like i just cannot
believe how skilled someone can be at
something so specific like playing cards
yeah like i went and saw shin lim um
with my kids and i mean i i just
it's like you're watching a movie yeah
it's crazy like it's i couldn't believe
andre was doing some tricks for jack and
i the other week and uh the same tricks
like six times
couldn't figure out yeah so he'd do a
trick where basically uh he'd fan out
cards and have us pick a card
and we would look at it and we put it
back in the deck he'd shuffle the deck
and then he would pull that card out of
his pocket his pocket and we're like how
did you do that he's like i'll do it
again for you and he did it multiple
times and i'm sitting there looking at
his pocket the entire time
and he does the same trick and he keeps
pulling it on like he he's not even
close hold it can you pull out of his
mouth one time oh yeah he was like doing
all this stuff with his hand and then
he's all and he just points up and then
we look up and there's a card in his
mouth and it's the card that we picked
yeah
yeah but he was calling that
misdirection because we were so focused
on the pocket now that he put it in his
mouth and we're focused on his mouth and
the pocket and he pulled it out of like
somewhere else it was insane i'm
convinced that people that do that stuff
can stop time
it's got to be something they have to be
there
and they take the card they look at it
they put it back in your hand and they
put the card in their pocket and then
they renew time like it's got to be
something like that it doesn't make any
sense
like if there's a there's an insane this
guy shouldn't limb you should see this
guy yeah i mean he's like
he had us go in the audience have you
seen the show no he had he had a trick
where
the audience all had cards and basically
you have to like rip them up in
different ways and then you throw them
away like whatever ones you you have and
then every single person in the audience
got the same card
like put back together yeah i saw the
show like that's an absolutely
incredible show it happens incredible
100 people in the audience and they all
got the same damn card
it's like crazy wow my kids three years
old six years old did the same thing
and they got the same card
like i was just
i just couldn't believe it you know i
just blew my mind i want to know how
they're done that's what i'm so curious
about
i just how do you do it there isn't
there like a show that does magic
exposed like there's a youtube channel
that shows you all the things that have
like magic exposed i think it is yeah
but a lot of these are custom tricks
that
they work on individually i think so
yeah like david copperfield is so
wealthy you know i heard david
copperfield's like a billionaire and
he's the one that designs all the tricks
and he like sells them to other people
sure i mean think about that that's like
it's got to be an insane business yeah
you know so niche
i think with the show that you guys are
talking about they can show like all the
the gimmicks like all the
like all the stuff that doesn't take
like much skill uh but nobody wants to
watch a tv show where you're talking
about sleight of hand for like 30
minutes like this is how you do this you
know by misdirecting here so it's like
it doesn't really reveal some of those
tricks that you guys yeah it's like the
cut in half or like the disappearance
yeah those big ones right yeah the
sleight of hand stuff probably not that
easy so yeah would that be a good that'd
be a good person to put on here i would
love that yeah he's he's our age yeah
he's in his 30s yeah right so that'd be
cool i don't know who else are you
thinking uh oh gosh uh we've had a list
if we want to get some some tick tock
people yeah we feel like that's the next
step uh because we've covered a lot of
youtube we want to get i actually
learned a new audience
like i was pretty surprised how
instagram and like how snapchat pays the
most yeah i would i had no idea so we're
starting on snapchat now yeah yeah me
too like literally like i i watch that
video and i text my phone guy and i was
like started snapchat right now yeah you
know uh i hope maybe that's a bad thing
maybe it's not going to pay as well
because there's so many people going to
go on it now the thing is
we're using um
what do you want to call companies or
like we're using
agencies who do this for us because
there's a strategy
to snapchat and facebook uh and even
tick tock that it's hard to replicate
like i know youtube really well sure but
what i'm doing in youtube would not be
applicable for facebook and it's like
relearning a new album this book is a
machine too like it blows my mind i have
a video that i put on um
youtube it only got like 500 some
thousand views got like three million
views on facebook in two weeks wow and
i'm just like what is this place like
how i don't understand maybe i should
stop making youtube videos like yeah and
going back and forth trying to figure it
out like who i have a different editor
for facebook so all of my youtube videos
have different cuts than you know
facebook so we re-cut them all so
they're like maybe the same person
watches it i don't know just like an
extended cut kind of thing and facebook
always makes like three to one more
money than youtube maybe even more
actually do you guys post these on
facebook uh not yet but we're planning
to yeah well the thing is what's great
about it is facebook's an older audience
yep right instagram and all the other
ones are very young
and so like youtube is kind of a younger
audience as well i mean youtube's a very
broad audience realistically but
like 20 year olds aren't on facebook
it's all like the 30 40 50 year olds
yeah the downside i will say at facebook
is that it's a big international
audience
so that means when you're targeting with
ads the ads generally pay lower but
there's a bigger audience to reach to
yeah well i think yeah definitely
running in play ads you know not like
just the facebook generated ads yeah the
ones that are you know we're getting
sponsored money and stuff for
those don't have the same um outreach
obviously unless you're selling a
product that can be shipped somewhere i
mean all the ads that you do are pretty
much
all us-based yeah but can you like sign
up with the stock things overseas or no
no no no even canada right now it's just
us-based is it okay
yeah some of those things are pretty
sweet yeah all that stuff that they come
up with so guys if you guys don't know
we actually have a patreon if you guys
want to sign down below um there's
different tiers some of the perks you
get to ask our guests some questions or
submit you know a chance for it to ask
them some questions and our highest here
um we're actually throwing some private
events about two times a year so if you
guys want to come hang out with us check
out the patreon and while you're um on
the patreon just go back to youtube go
to the description and then follow me on
instagram my link is down below and so
yeah you know so now we're going to ask
some patreon questions from some of our
members no patreon questions oh really
now we're not going to ask some patreon
questions from some of our members it
was last night at 8pm i'm not you didn't
ask earlier what did that's girlie no
jack andrew you better leave this
do you want to do it
yeah
good job
all right no no no here's the drama i
have no login to patreon i have no idea
i will gladly give you the login i can't
do it that's the thing it's like you
can't either i can't you have all the
employees jack what you have all the
employees we have the same amount
of contracts
i like that so first of all graham likes
to take on new things right which is
great
entrepreneurial mindset right that's
what you do but the thing is as soon as
he takes on any new thing especially
with regard to the iced coffee hour it
basically defaults that the
responsibility is put on me so he came
up with the idea of creating a patreon
and i said i love the idea of the
patreon but i already told him i
remember that one of the first things i
said as soon as we start the patreon i
know that the responsibility is going to
be put on me and i think that this is
something that we should discuss right
and i was like oh no it'll be fine i'll
be fine and of course the patreon
happens graham has not logged into the
patreon once he hasn't gone back to
anybody on the patreon at all i get back
to every single message we've gotten on
the patreon i'm posting every single
podcast early on the patreon i'm asking
questions for them to ask to our guests
on every patreon thing and then one time
i post it late at 8 30 pm the night
before right and this is 12 they have
they had 12 hours to ask questions to
you and sure maybe i could have posted
it earlier but graham didn't even think
about it once didn't think about texting
the thing
he didn't think about texting me hey
jack post on the patreon he doesn't
remind me for any of this stuff
basically the responsibility
automatically gets shifted over to me
and graham sits on the side okay
i'll gladly take care of this for a few
years no our agreement jack jack was
gonna handle everything in the back end
including editing there was sponsors
scripting everything back and jack was
gonna handle i was going to handle the
title thumbnail being physically here
and coordinating guests
and so to me everything else in the back
end is the responsibility of jack
right but the backhand has been handled
by me and and then we add on the patreon
which was a thing that was outside but
it was outside of the scope with that
stuff that we initially agree with but
the thing is patreon how much how much
money have you earned from the patreon
okay
i'm just sharing yeah it's like i mean
we started like three weeks ago and we
have like
fifteen to sixteen hundred dollars
but yes that's your responsibility
why
because you're the back end
but this was outside of the scope of
scope but it's also outside of the scope
of the income too
yeah i know but we never okay so if
you're seeing this as one independent
project we never talked about the terms
and the workload of this independent
project it just defaulted to my thing
i just i feel like because you're
getting paid for it right that it's an
additional income and it's an additional
work right if it was free and you guys
had a patreon and it was another thing
that wasn't an income right then i would
agree that maybe graham should should
take a roll because he's doing the a
very small amount right and you're doing
a very large amount but because there's
an income added to it right that is
using the likeness of the iced coffee
hour and everything like that it falls
in line with the back end
only because there's an income that's my
opinion i think houston worded that
perfectly couldn't have said it better
myself
yeah i think that's a that is a very
strong argument but at the same time
like i said we agreed on some set like
some set responsibilities okay this is
good but those responsibilities were
designed on the incomability of this
iced coffee hour it weren't they weren't
designed on the new additional income
from the future projects that the iced
coffee hour brings so like that's also
an assumption well it's an assumption
that it's going to make money yes but if
in three weeks you've made 1600 and
you've split that appropriately right
then the the same rules apply you know
because it's an auxiliary option to the
iced coffee hour but then you have to
think about this
like
to the nth degree right imagine graham
starts
adding on all these other
responsibilities all these other
verticals that somehow correlate back to
the iced coffee hour right i mean still
your income would scale in proportion to
that yeah i know what you would do with
that let's say there was like an
enormous amount of responsibilities that
the two of you agreed that you would
need a third person right and that would
cover a salary and then that would come
off the top of all of the items combined
right so let's say the iced coffee are
made ten thousand dollars a month right
and you need to pay someone a thousand
to help you out with all these things
and so to limit some of your
responsibilities limit some of your
responsibilities and you both agreed to
take it off the top and then you would
split after that would make sense so
there's gonna become a time where
patreon turns into like 10 other things
right right now if it's at the maximum
capability of your workload then i think
that you you agree you stay with this
and then this is what you tell graham
like hey look this is this is it i can't
add any more responsibilities than these
particular items so if we add one more
thing we need to bring on someone else
so i think with regards to the patreon
and anything else that we add on the
podcast realistically something grandma
i've been talking about for a while now
is that we need a producer of the
podcast agreed basically that handles
all this stuff so we let the host be the
host and then we let someone else
basically be managing the back end and
having it flush the thing is i'm good at
it right i'm finding it i've been doing
it for a very long time but i know that
out there there's someone that's better
and there's someone that's going to be
more diligent more structured that's
what cost right i mean how could what
would you pay your producers so we've
talked about so we've talked about this
salary but what do you think the salary
would be
should we go on record to say it
i'm on record
i'm on record as telling jack i don't
think we need a producer maybe not yet
but i mean let's just say you did hire a
producer would you pay them five
thousand dollars a month i mean at what
how much are you willing to to pay them
for for that i don't think yeah i don't
think that's a lot of money i don't
think it makes any sense to have a
producer
but you did you told me literally like a
month and a half ago that you wanted it
no
that was from one of your existing
contractors who could take on some
additional work to help us out yeah to
step into the position of the producer
and then you were all but there's no but
there's not like dedicated producers you
also mentioned someone that has never
worked in the business whatsoever before
and they just at this time did not have
a job and you're like oh we could move
them into the position of producer we
could try them out for a few months you
said that to me at the gym i remember it
was a month ago because we're not
working because they were willing to
work at a price that like if you get a
good deal exactly of course and then
it's like well then it just makes sense
you'll find something for them to do but
to go out of our way to find a podcast
producer so like that's what i'm saying
right so like if you took your
contractor that was making let's say 500
right now for their work and said hey
can you take on this amount of
responsibilities that's going to take
we'll give them 500 more but that 500
you can turn into 5 000 or 15 000 or
some excess amount of money you can flip
that money and their responsibilities
will return you 10 15 20 x that makes
sense but like to hire a producer to run
the show and pay them
a normal salary that i would consider
maybe five eight thousand dollars
between that area that they could run
the show because of the size of the show
i mean you don't have a small view count
right you have a lot of views and so you
know that producer would then respond to
you know the the
questions the comments it would take on
your role essentially right and you
would become more of like a gram roll
you know so that would that would be the
only way i see this you know transition
what roi do you see it worth it like
obviously spending let's just say 50
grand to make 50 grand that's that's not
good no no you need 10. i in my my book
like i don't start a new project unless
i'm getting 10x right like i was offered
to invest in so many things in the past
couple of months and you know at 10
return at 20 return
it's just it's not worth the risk right
so for you to take on that
responsibility
hiring someone is more risky than an
investment right because you're taking
on their livelihood unless it's a
contractor and it's a very small amount
of money and they understand that but
like when you're talking about taking on
someone full time this becomes their job
they have to pay their rent they have to
pay their stuff and you're responsible
for their bills their lifestyle right so
you have to commit to them as well as
they have to commit to you so you have
to see at least 10x from that position
you know like if they're paying them
five you've got to return 50. so they've
got to be getting you extra sponsors
right they've got to be reaching out to
to
i don't know someone that is going to
bring in more money right so i hired a
producer for my youtube and and you know
digital business yeah right and they
signed um a deal with the company that
brought me 200 000 in ads
right over a course of time so i paid
that person you know 25 000
right like a 12 commission for that
right because i got this long-term
contract so that was worth it right i
mean would you give me 12 grand if i
gave you back 200. absolutely yeah right
so like i think the same thing has to
follow like with the patreon right now
it's only bringing you sixteen hundred
or two thousand dollars right so that
responsibility is probably gonna have to
lie on you but if it starts to bring in
10 12 15 20 000 then you can afford to
say look this is auxiliary income we
didn't expect this right we should use
this money together to add someone to
help us oversee this business and grow
it you know that's my opinion i think
10x return is totally feasible i agree i
think for a producer yeah yeah i think
it's absolutely fine i don't i don't see
it what i think is that since i've been
here for three months ago or two months
ago right you've increased the the the
podcast has gained 30 percent more
income but that's total amount
and it's solely that's youtube i don't
know what a producer would give us
different from sponsorships which i
don't know what a producer would would
give for us that we can't already do
with what we're already doing but we
aren't doing it what are we doing
okay first of all for the thing uh
midweeks every single week sometimes we
just don't have anything to talk about
that's that's nothing a producer would
would well the producer needs to tell
yeah i'm saying that particularly
the right i mean they have to reach out
to guys like myself or alex or whoever
is going to come on this show and say
look we need to schedule wednesday and
saturday or wednesday and sunday
that producer needs to fill this seat
every week twice a week that's their job
right they need to break down the
content they need to say look houston
you're going to talk about these topics
today right and be prepared for these
topics because this is what we want to
talk about you know and for me just to
come on here and talk i mean we're
friends so you know we have mutual
respect we have a lot in common we can
make that conversation but when it's
someone you've never met before somebody
needs to do research
exactly
i would say have have andrew do it i
don't want okay so also also another
thing is you have to consider the
workload that some of your contractors
or for some other people employees are
bearing right of course just to
automatically add more workload in i
think is is dangerous i think i don't
like to burn out my i think
be a great test it tests the proof of
concept and if they like it it's a step
up if they don't then or if it doesn't
work or if we're not seeing the roi then
we lose nothing and and they get the
benefit of trying it out
sometimes you have to burn the burn burn
the wick at both ends to see what works
i agree if we take on yeah you in my
opinion you know when you have
contractors right i mean obviously if
that contractor has 10 other clients
right you have to know that right you
can't take a contractor that's already
an 80 hour workload and be like hey
here's 20 more right they're just
they're not going to perform for you
right they're not going to perform for
the other people and then they're going
to get stressed and their work's going
to just be worthless so you definitely
want to get someone who can commit to
you and say look i'm going to give you
go to your your contractor andrew and
say look andrew i'm going to give you
three months okay i'm going to pay you
this much money and i want this result
if you can contribute to that then we
can bring you one full time and you
don't have to worry about the other
clients that you have we can afford to
pay you this much and you'd be solely
you know working for us or you know a
balance of 50 of your income will come
from us right so that should be for you
guys and my personal opinion is twice a
week consistency is what's going to pay
you right consistency is what's going to
get you those ads those better views
it's better everything right and you
need diversity right i mean iced coffee
are amazing you've got diversity right
now i mean you've got some really cool
people on here but like i said i mean
you need some people that are going to
bring the view ratio i mean i guarantee
if you look at this particular portion
of the podcast and watch the view count
or you know watch the the duration it's
going to spike oh people always love our
it's great i mean we're talking with
emotion right now and we're talking
about something interesting but we're
also solving a problem you know so if
you can get that producer to do some
research on let's say
some person get some background right
find someone with some drama like what
happened with this i remember there was
a guy on here that had like a bunch of
drama um at one time and you were a lot
of people were commenting negative about
it
yeah yeah i don't really know i didn't i
didn't really understand that because i
don't know what happened before but i
watched it yeah i thought it was like
interesting but like that producer needs
to know what's happening in that
person's life what they're into
interview them first talk about their
stuff and bring you that content so you
guys can utilize that here and not just
hope for the best that's grand returns
also because if we do too much research
on our own end then it makes the entire
conversation planned exactly right so i
agree a producer would be great for that
role and also it's the structure it's
like i think that there are a few things
that i i like to think i'm at least
uniquely good at i have a competitive
advantage in right and i think structure
is like the exact opposite of what i
have a competitive advantage in and
that's what a producer needs
and i think that's why i really don't
think that i would be good at
structuring out these guests giving out
time slots posting my patreon at a
certain time i think you know i don't
have great i know but i think it's a 15
hour a week
job that's what i think i in terms of
outreach and all of this you have so
much the contract that we would pass
this on to does great work do amazing
work and i don't want to just throw you
know i'll throw them into a spiral
because i right well of course i would i
would present the opportunity to them
but you got to commit to him i mean if
you're going to have him do this you've
got to give him three months and say
you're guaranteed now after month one if
he sucks you've got to deal with him for
month two and then after month two if he
sucks you gotta give him that third
month it's gonna take someone some time
to get used to their role right they
might have the skill set and not know
how to utilize it yet they might you
know have a bad first two three weeks
and get discouraged but them guaranteed
you guys guaranteeing them three months
to give them the idea to figure it out
is going to help him come into that role
yeah i like a three-month test i think
within three months by the end of it we
should see whether or not it's working i
agree yeah yeah i think this is uh this
is a really cool thing you've got going
on and i would love to see this expanded
right i mean just for my own personal
entertainment right these are
90 one hour and two hour videos that are
very engaging right and and you have the
potential to take this to a very
very high level right that no one really
has i mean graham graham's celebrity in
this industry is is worth watching just
to hear his opinion right because
obviously he does so much research so if
you can get that same back end for for
the other side of this i think that'd be
great i'm open to it part of it is
difficult for me because i really take a
lot of pride in keeping things small and
like the team is right here yeah and so
that is what i think has kept us like
really grounded and
you know i mean this is his business yes
so you have so many other things going
on yeah you have so much other income
from other places it's it's unfair to to
both these guys right because their
income's coming from here right and so
it's you need to obviously build it for
them as well i mean he's putting in more
work physically than you are right and
you're getting the same benefit if not
more you know whatever it is right so at
the end of the day i think um
being small is cool because you have all
those things but you know jack has a
miata so like
and alexis
i told him by a lotus elise but uh
didn't listen yeah
so yeah yeah i think that's good man
i'm happy thank you for your insights
really good insight yeah yeah so if uh
if you guys ever need anybody to mediate
you know i like this thank you man yeah
i got a couple random finance questions
for you do it okay so
if you were to get a pie of all of your
assets how would like the slices be
arranged all right um
so i have uh 60
in cars because i know that business the
best i have 20
percent
in cash and then i have about
10
in commercial real estate and then the
other 10 in like nft [ __ ] what about
your house i don't know rents yeah i
rent right now how much does your rent
thirty thousand
a month yeah
my theory it's a nice big house man i
have a cool house and like to to my
defense on the rental uh it's not that i
don't wanna own a home but
basically to own a i live in a little
over seven million dollar house and like
that house would be
30 down to do a mortgage on and at the
rates that i when i started renting was
about four and a half percent the
mortgage would have been more than i
rent and that 30 percent down would have
been around two two two three to two
million
and i feel like with the two and a half
million dollars i can make 30 000 a
month with ease yeah so i saved that
money i rent this house
it pays for itself you know it's free to
me right and i know i don't get the
benefits of write-offs right with the
interest and all that stuff but
if i were to buy like i considered
buying like a cheap two million dollar
house like in in like a nice
neighborhood to kind of like chill out
in cheap right cheap two million dollars
well in comparison to
right the cheapest house in the sky is
actually the one i live in
currently yeah it was seven million
right because like the other ones are
like 10 12 15 whatever there's only 30
something houses in that neighborhood
but like the i have the cheapest one and
so you know i was thinking to myself
like maybe if i just take this money and
i
hold on to it right right now in cash i
have just about 2 million bucks right i
just bought this pagani and um so i took
uh i put half down on the pagani and i
financed the rest and i did the same
with my koenigsegg so you know i don't
want to leverage too too hard on those
cars but i also don't want to put down
too much money as well and so like i was
thinking to myself you know like
my my overall like debt load you know my
pagani is 20 000 and my koenigsegg's 35
000 a month and those are the only two
cars i have financed and so like i'm
thinking to myself like how do i you
know the rest of them are paid for as
like an investment you know the gt-rs
the ford gts and all those things veyron
yeah the veyron um the vaporeon i built
so it's a little bit unique but um to
leverage that you know i can write off
the cars like the 35 and the 20. i can
write that off because i use them for
youtube right so those are great
write-offs for me
and um
i have like a good balance you know and
i know the liquidity of those things
right with houses and with real estate
like i have a commercial piece of land
that i'm building a uh dispensary a
liquor store on right it's a ridiculous
location it's like it was like winning
the lottery for me to get this piece of
land and that's paid for no debt you
know and i'm building a building with no
debt so i feel like at the end of the
day you know
my situation is based on my geographical
location in las vegas right and the
ability that i have to move around with
that you know
and all that that 10 percent of nfts and
crypto and investments was just a waste
you know i mean hopefully it'll turn out
to do something but like i bought a
board ape
why how much was it 800 no yeah
800 grand i was thinking like 300.
i partnered with uh wow
and another guy
and so
um
we have a we have a board ape together i
have actually three board apes i've got
a mutant and i have two mutants and yeah
have you gone to any of the events what
does it do for you
haven't you
so why do you buy it just
ah because i'm
i was like all into this nft crypto
thing like for a little while and i was
like super stoked about it and i bought
it because i thought someone was gonna
pay more
that's the problem with the world man
what happened to these
well they're worth the same amount of
money in ethereum if not more i think
they're actually i think my board ape
was actually worth more than i paid for
i paid 200 ethereum but ethereum's four
thousand dollars when i bought it so if
i get 200 ethereum back i'll have one
quarter of my money right so if i get
250 ethereum back i'll have made a
profit on my ethereum but then the
ethereum value is so low right i end up
losing money so that's an interesting
way to look at it yeah because if you if
you're going to keep your money in the
ethereum anyway you just want that
ethereum back plus some yeah regardless
of its value that's it and that's a
really interesting way to think about it
there was a board ape that was sold
recently for um
800
ethereum or 860 ethereum it was a gold
one so that that tells me that people
are still buying them right but that's
860 000 versus like 2.5 billion it's
really for the people putting money in
ethereum now so now they're able to buy
it cheaper unless they already had their
money in ethereum and it was worth
whatever anyway i mean i don't see
nfts are a weird thing
um there's this taxable thing there's a
lot of like art there's a lot of
balances around nfts and then gary
vernerchuk talks about web3 and like a
bunch of stuff with that i mean there's
there's some future i think with nfts
but at the end of the day right now i
mean i'm a pretty firm believer that nft
is just a jpeg on the internet yeah i
don't think there's any intrinsic value
the value of the nft is in verifying
who's the owner and so i think what like
like if you buy a gucci bag or a rolex
there should be an nft with that group
that verifies that you are the owner of
that rolex that is yours it's the same
with any and it costs nothing
to to do that on a large scale like any
designer item should have an nft with it
yep which makes the most sense because
then you can
the product itself is raised right it's
gonna really help with counterfeits it
would eliminate count right people would
it would be just you have a counterfeit
or you don't have counterfeit but like
imagine changing title for a car but
that's done on the blockchain it'll be
so much yeah oh my gosh it would be an
instant
oh there's a way you could give
licensing or ownership to someone uh
that would be interesting but i don't
know how each video would be treated
separately so like someone could buy my
video let's just say and they get the ad
revenue it's kind of like a song yeah
that's actually i'm sure there's a way
to do it but that's the thing right now
there's so many great ideas right it's
just executing them and bringing them
into a mass market to actually monetize
them are so difficult you know i think
boarded did a really good job of
building a brand right i mean they built
a brand it's not just the end of t they
built a brand around the apes and and
they they've contributed so well and the
reason people want board apes is and the
reason why i wanted to buy a board ape
is because they airdrop so much value
right so the mutant serums that we got
were free
right and intrinsically those those
turned into 30 40 000 assets um they
airdropped apecoin right based on your
uh the value you paid or i don't know
how exactly they did it but i i got my
portion was twenty six thousand dollars
in apecoin for free and that was when it
was only twelve dollars when i first got
it right it actually went to twenty
something dollars so i sold it
immediately because i didn't want to
hold it but
i got 26 000
like real money for free right and so
like these guys that are air dropping
auxiliary items because they want the
residuals right they want them traded
back and forth so they get the
commissions right the nft structure is
so good for the creator because of
commissions you know for me i would love
to change my rental car business into
like a membership program with an nft
you know i've thought about it and it
just
it takes a very intelligent person it's
way smarter than me to really fine-tune
that business plan but i mean imagine
just having a card like a like i bought
one of the knuck boys cards just to have
it right it was like 3 000 bucks it was
one one uh at the time yeah and um
it allows me to have access to all their
events which they haven't thrown at an
event from my understanding or whatever
one did they yeah with snoop dogg okay
so yeah i was i would have been able to
go to that but like if i did that for my
rental car business and i created like a
meta card
and it gave you access to see i think
that the real good version of this would
be car sales you have access to you're
part of my dealership network right and
i sell you cars based on the auction
value right versus based on the retail
value
so you give me 3001 ethereum right you
hold this card you buy it and um you
hold it until you want to purchase a car
or you purchase many cars right and it
gives you access to buy these cars from
me at a 12 to 13 15 discount from retail
right and save all those fees you know
so i think that there's a good business
plan for that and then it allows you to
rent cars at cost or allows you to rent
private jets at cost you know being a
member in this and being very limited
would make sense and it'd make those
cards value grow right so if you paid
three thousand someone might pay you
five thousand because they're looking to
buy a mercedes and they don't have the
ability to buy at an auction they'll buy
my card and then get a mercedes from me
and save 15 000
right so like there's like so many cool
ideas to do with nfts and blockchains
and cards and everything but
it sucks to like market against the
industry yeah you know you have like
that push of where i've got a great idea
but how do i combat all of the fraud
that's in the industry and the notion
that nfts are fake or whatever they are
going on in the media right how do i say
that i have a really good idea this is a
good product but i'm you know i'm trying
to battle that as well so it's difficult
to like scale it sure you know are there
any business ideas that you're not doing
that you wouldn't mind sharing
you might think it's a good idea so you
don't have the resources for it that was
a good one actually yeah um i do think
that um we need to create a bring a
trailer have you been on that website
all the time for houses
would be difficult without the without
the inspection they they used to have
you do an inspection pre pre the listing
think about this they've tried doing
that in the past all of them have failed
i haven't done it like bring a trailer
right now
it's bringing a trailer so easy because
it's so simple and the commission that
bring a trailer takes is very minuscule
but with cars it's a lot easier to place
a bid than with the house to make sure
that buyers pre approved because you
don't necessarily need to sell for the
highest price you want to sell to the
buyer is going to close of course and so
if someone offers 100k but the best
buyer is 90k all cash no contingencies
you need to view all the offers and
select the ones based on who's most
likely to close that's just
that just depends on the type of house
the type of buyer you want because you
can open your house up and limit it
right i mean if if we posted a house
that was 200 000
and you wanted to only accept a certain
amount of offer your buyer pull would
just be able to bid on that right you'd
have different levels i only want cash
offers and this is the price that the
cash offers would take you know like it
just
has to be different ground rules yeah
it's tough because you need mls exposure
on those and generally these exposures
generally with the auctions you don't
get the same level of interest because
people are waiting for a certain date i
think it was auction.com that used to do
this throughout like 2010 to 2013. it
was really popular now it's like those
were but those were bank-owned
properties and they never and and a lot
of those banks just had to do that
because they had no other options so
they just put them up there with a
really low reserve but now in today's
economy i just i can't see that i just
think that the auction mentality is
normal now right ebay was the only
auction in a long time ago right now
everything is sold at like a bidding
price
right so i do think that there's like
plus just because you get the hundred
thousand dollar winner doesn't mean you
know
that person has to close i mean you have
the other two three backup people
look you we don't have to think through
this right now yeah i'm just saying that
i think
that because of the the way that the
pandemic changed our mentality
no one knows what
you know it maybe it doesn't have to be
an auction where you win it's more of
like you put it up for 14 days and this
is my bid and then you pick through
those right it's just like a public
offering system right so it's on the mls
and instead of writing a contingent
offer through the real estate agent not
knowing like i wanted to buy a house a
couple weeks ago for an investment and
i i put in a specific offer and the real
estate was like nah man we got way
better offers than that well what if
they didn't and what if it was public
and what if it was like my offer was the
strongest but they were trying to screw
me and get me a better one well even if
it is public you could always tell your
friend to go and bid on a house or you
know submit something yeah i mean i
don't know i think you just like bring a
trailer charges you for the bids which
is super cool like when you make a bid
you have to pay for it now if you don't
win they give you your money back yeah
well it's the deposit yeah what is it
five grand or it's they put up they put
a hole up to a certain amount or it's a
five percent of the price i feel like
there's something there there's some way
to make it to where we could eliminate
the realtors opinion in a purchase i
think this is a real problem i'm very
against realtors because their opinion
is the issue i don't think so i think
it's their expertise that you really pay
for the expertise yeah it's the
experience now obviously but but just
the same thing like with any business
there are good business people and there
are terrible ones yeah i think with real
estate
99.99 of realtors are are based on their
own pockets i mean the reality is 20 of
the agents are really doing the majority
of the business and the top five percent
do they mean
what do you think of people that are
buying their houses for
let's say in 2021 they bought their
house for 1.4 and then they posted it
for 3.2 today
is that a problem with the agent or
probably the seller no that's a problem
with the market i don't think it's the
agent or the seller if that if that
house is worth three million dollars
they would be they would be asking three
million
right and hoping for the best i mean
there's no there's no comps based on
that right well obviously the market's
going to always dictate what people get
so a lot of times for my sellers they
would say well i want to list it you
know why why list it this price versus
other prices the market will always
dictate it but it's it's marketing so if
you're if your home is worth 1.1 and you
list it at 9.99 your home is going to
sell way over based on what the market's
worth if you over price your home so the
market will eventually sell what it's
worth but then you're wasting all the
momentum in the beginning yeah so i
think a lot of its strategy there is an
element of marketing that you have to
just like with anything
but i think the expertise is in figuring
out where the balance is and then the
market will dictate what the home is
worth your home is not worth you know a
million dollars if it sits on the market
for six months it was never worth that
to begin with yeah or it could be really
bad marketing and you missed the market
in the beginning
i just right now it seems like
everybody's just shooting for the stars
and they're like oh in this market i
mean in this market means that the
government gave everybody six trillion
dollars and they spent it and they were
like oh well hey this is worth this much
money because i have this extra money
yeah but a lot of those are based on
comps and so if you if you have some one
guy to buy one house to get one comp and
then another one no daisy chain company
you're never looking at just one house
especially in a place like vegas you're
looking at the almost the entire city
and what you could get you're probably
looking at 10 to 30 different comps and
taking the average of all of those based
on square footage
but i just think that's not happening
right now i don't know if you're looking
at it's but you could always pick one
off comps if you want to like let's say
a skya you could look at one sale
because there's really nothing in there
it's so funny about the sky yeah they're
not selling
right but you could you can look at the
one that sold and say based on this one
that sold but when you expand beyond a
half a mile and you see wait a second
everything else is selling for 20 less
how do we compare with that
so you could always find a one-off comp
and sometimes sellers will do that and
that's unrealistic but overall you got
to look at 20 or 30 different homes i
agree it just i don't think it's
happening right half the time by the way
or i would say probably 90 of the time
the homes being priced high or not the
agents the agents if anything have a
financial incentive to price it low it's
the sellers and agents are like well
crap do i just not want to take the
listing because if they don't take the
listing someone else will of course so
they're just like well i may as well
take the listing at this high price the
seller insists on
and then maybe i could talk some cents
after a few weeks they don't get an
offer and we could come down to
something more realistic but these are
sellers who have no idea what they're
doing and if anything if they have
better guidance from an agent or a
consultant they might not price their
home that high because the agents have a
better pulse of what's going on and they
don't want to waste three weeks or let's
even say months of their time and energy
and money to actually pay
i mean the agents are paying their
marketing they're paying absolutely
doing that so it's costing some money if
anything it's better for the agents to
price lower but it's the sellers i mean
just from
just anecdotal stuff that i've seen it
just seems like people have an
unrealistic expectation of what their
home is worth based on values six months
ago and they're sticking with it and
there aren't enough
agents are desperate for any listings if
they're if they're you know maybe not
doing as well they'll take anything so
and those are the people that say well
okay let's go ahead and do it but the
good agents and from at least what i've
seen uh will turn down listings if they
don't believe they could sell it in a
realistic time frame they'll just say no
it makes them look bad right you know
there's there's a group of agents here
in town that just take
everything high-end and they just post
it for whatever the price they want i
mean it's like astronomical numbers and
it just takes one to sell right for them
to get good money but at the end of the
day it's like it's it's wild of how much
people want i just don't think that
people understand how the housing market
like should work right as buyers you
know it shouldn't go up 150 percent in
one year right like houses shouldn't
raise that much because they shouldn't
but that doesn't mean they can't or
that's of course they can't but now when
you buy it at that price it's gonna come
down right because it can't do it again
well it just depends on what your
mortgage rate is i mean if you buy a
home at a two and a half percent
mortgage rate in your payments you know
five thousand dollars a month let's just
say even if home prices go down 20
percent but interest rates are now six
percent your payment could be the exact
same yeah yeah so it just really just
like depends 20 drops based on like
like i don't know i i guess
because i'm on the other side of the
fence right i want to be a buyer right
sometimes and i want to be a seller
sometimes you know everybody wants to to
to hold both cards right you want to be
the one that sells the highest amount
and want to buy the cheapest house so
it's it's tough i just i've lived in
vegas so long that we used to be a city
of value and now it's like cheaper to
live in california like i wouldn't say
that hey no
no gosh no
gosh no not at all it's way cheaper here
it's my joke but yeah i mean i've never
seen the five eight nine one thousand a
square foot it was like 250 300 and now
every house is 500 plus yeah you know i
think there's an element to that that
can be sustained just because of how
many people are continuing to move here
um and i think generally the worse
california gets the better vegas is
going to do yeah so i want more people
to come here i want them because they're
going to eat at my restaurant right i
mean the more overpopulated vegas gets
the more dense it gets but i will say
the one thing that would hurt nevada is
if they get rid of the the salt cap
so if they get rid of that in california
they bring down taxes a little bit and
they improve the areas i think we'll
start to see
either fewer people moving out of state
or maybe you might see some of the
people that left coming back yeah i
actually can see that i mean
right now in my
my research all i see is homes that were
purchased in 2020 and 2021 for sale in
2022. like there really isn't anybody
selling a home that bought it before
2020. i mean that just like nobody right
and some people are just buying a house
and three months later putting it back
for sale right like yeah well i think a
lot of that is just the the surprise and
the shock of just wow how much money i
just made in such a short amount of time
like for the properties that i had
bought in 2016 or 17
it's less of a shock because you've seen
the incremental price you're used to it
but when you buy a home two years ago
it's like wow in two years i just made
six hundred thousand dollars maybe it's
a good i myself i think those are the
people we're more likely to sell my
theory is that everybody's like moved to
vegas and realized that it wasn't a good
idea to live here because the summer
it's hot or this or that or they don't
like the
something about the city and they're
moving back or they're moving somewhere
else i've never seen anybody move back
yeah people that i've seen sell or
selling because they either have too
much space they bought too big of a
house um they they maybe learn the area
a little bit better and they want to
move somewhere else
those are the people that i'm seeing
selling i just i don't see how you sell
it
a high amount
with a three percent mortgage and go
into a six percent mortgage at a higher
amount
oh i don't see that
that's why but that's why a lot of
people are also just not selling yeah
like i wouldn't want to sell this house
i i've been so tempted to just because
of value's going up but i would hate to
move and i don't i have a 2.8 percent
mortgage on this so it's like like a
million dollars more at least yeah so
it's like it doesn't make sense to sell
sorry like i don't want to get rid of
that mortgage
i agree
you know that's why i think people
should stay yeah and then bring the
prices of the houses down a little bit
because the more people well if they the
more they stay the less inventory
there's gonna be so you'd want people to
leave and list their homes because if
everyone was like well i'm going to give
up my mortgage then
there'll be way more inventory and
prices would come down but if people
stay then they don't need a new house
well if people stay if if if people stay
then there's going to be less inventory
so anyone who does want to move is going
to have less to pick from in my own
perfect scenario uh which is probably
not gonna happen
prices stay the same and maybe increase
like let's just say the floor is now a
million bucks
that floor stays the same and maybe
increases at a rate of two to four
percent the year after that just
basically in line with what i would
consider to be a reasonable inflation
yeah that's what i would like to see so
we don't see a crash but we don't see
prices continuing to skyrocket we just
see stability do you think we're in a
recession oh yeah yeah yeah i do do you
think that they're going to announce
something that says we're interested uh
i think it's september that they
actually come out and make the the
proper announced the official
announcement but by then it's usually
too late like right yeah it's it's it
seems it's like two years are gone right
uh usually they they've found that once
they announce we're in a recession the
worst is already over
um
and that the the peak tends to happen
six months prior to the worst of a
recession
so so right now like this could be i
mean it depends the the peak of the
market was back in let's say november
december january
we're past six months of that
who knows i mean it could continue to
get worse it's just it's difficult to i
guess
dictate what's happening outside of
america right like i mean you have these
wars you have all this stuff going on
and that's out of our control and that
really drives our market down you know
yeah so it's like there's so many other
factors today right well i think a lot
of it is the fear and higher interest
rates yeah and you think they're gonna
go to nine ten percent no i think
they're gonna hit stop it like no i
don't there's this mortgage guy i follow
in los angeles he's one of like the
biggest mortgage brokers and he sent an
email i think two months ago
saying that from his experience of like
40 years in the mortgage industry that
he believes mortgage mortgage rates have
already peaked and that they've already
priced in all the future fed rate
increases and that we're not going to
see seven or eight percent mortgages he
thinks honestly mortgages are gonna stay
between five and six and a half percent
maybe bob a little bit plus or minus you
know a tad in between there
i could see that
becoming true well i noticed that they
have lowered the rate a couple mortgage
rates last week yes mortgage rates
dropped from i think six and a half to
like five and a half percent something
uh in a matter of a few weeks just
because demand was drying up and so
mortgage rates came down so it makes
sense to me jerome powell raising the
rates right he's raising the prime rate
right so the bank is adding their fees
right right so the bank is the one
dictating the five six seven eights
right that's where the bank's money's at
so the bank sees zero demand or less
demand they're going to lower those
rates off the prime rate the bank's
going to make less money and you know
interest rates it's all going to be
supply and demand um so i think if we
see less demand um we're going to see
mortgage rates come down so i think
that's that's pretty true i think the
hardest part is going to be if the fed
raises the rates let's say three and a
half percent four percent um when you
have a savings account that's offering
three and a half to four percent
interest it's gonna pull a lot of money
away from the market like why would you
invest in stocks to maybe make seven to
eight percent when you could get a
guaranteed three and a half to four in a
savings account have access to your
money not lose it uh people forget i
think it was 2018 a savings account was
the best investment you could have made
seriously making 2018 yeah 2018. savings
account was the because the stock market
went down
uh asset prices went down real estate
went down i think it was like a percent
or something negligible but a savings
account was the only profitable thing
you could have invested in that year
and that made like one and a half
percent two percent oh
bitcoin or no that was when it was down
it was like yeah the savings that was
the best event so sometimes people
forget it's like that can be now
obviously that also would have been a
really good time to invest in the stock
market because it was underperforming
look at it now
so i like so much diversity that's the
that's why i like chicken so much right
because you could do medium mild
really hard so much diversity so much
diversity yeah right you just if like
the miami is performing well just throw
a restaurant in miami right if if
overseas is performing well
international expansion right i mean
it's just it's not bad everywhere right
that's what's good about chicken is that
you could just move it around just like
stocks or bonds or all these things i
mean
not everybody's gonna do bad right in a
recession it's only half or a portion of
companies go down and the porsche
companies go up you know yeah so you
just have to move your money around and
that's the best way
you know so
i don't think i have any other
businesses that i i want to do other
than like
i did want to start like a shoe cleaning
company
no one cleans shoes
like there's dry cleaners there's like
car washes there's like everybody but
nobody actually cleans that service oh
yeah he's doing
houston's shoe collection man you guys
don't understand that's i think that's
where the biggest problem my life is is
uh this addiction to shoes that i have
what okay so
that's probably like a real issue are
you into fashion yeah
i mean it's ironic that the first
no one knows this everybody's gonna know
now but i went to fashion school for a
few weeks that was my dad actually
manufactured denim and so he was a a
very world-renowned like denim designer
and he had like a bunch of manufacturing
facilities in la and made denim he's
he's 74 so he retired like when i was in
high school still and um so i originally
wanted to be in the denim industry so
you know i wanted to kind of like do
that and i went to fashion school for a
couple weeks and just realized la wasn't
for me like fedem was like really cool
but it just fit him yeah it wasn't my
vibe yeah you know but uh so yeah
anyways i i love fashion so what is it
about shoes that has such an allure to
people because i know shoes are really
popular amongst like shoes are election
right it's an accessory because okay so
like let me put it perspective like a
really cool designer t-shirt is like 500
right it's like very expensive for a
t-shirt but those t-shirts have no
resale value right jeans few five three
to four hundred dollars for jeans no
resale value
shoes for some reason are like watches
and they have resale value they actually
can be worth more money than you pay for
them like a lot of different types of
shoes are like that so there's this
collector-esque about it right and you
can now obviously if you don't wear them
they're worth way more money right but
if you do wear them they're still worth
money so this is why shoes are so
popular now is that like i have a couple
employees that flip shoes for a side
hustle
like it's a thing you know and um like
there's a new uh supreme or a virgil
collab with louis vuitton coming out and
i was told that some of those shoes
would be worth upwards of fifty thousand
dollars for a pair that's a legitimate
business when you buy a pair of shoes
for a few thousand dollars one to two or
whatever they cost from louis vuitton
and are able to sell them for fifty
thousand i don't know where the buyers
are for that but it's a real thing you
know and so i think there's no one that
caters to those guys
right i mean if you have 15 20 30 50
pairs of shoes you can't throw them in
the washer
right and there's no service that comes
to your house and like in a van and just
clean them
you know
so i think that's a good business idea
for someone i thought about doing like a
small franchise where i buy like a bunch
of like 20 year old kids their first job
get a van get them all their equipment
everything and then start like an app
and then people just want to like go
wash your shoes and then send a van out
like a mobile car wash service
but i don't know if that's very
effective
you would be the biggest customer
there's a lot actually there's so many
people like that i would definitely be a
huge customer um right now um i um i
have a guy that that basically does
other things for me kind of like a
handyman type guy and he he he does that
particular job for me wow yeah so i give
him ten twelve dollars a shoe depending
on which one it is but i'm gonna have
250 pairs 300 pairs of shoes so it adds
up for him over the month
you know gosh yeah i just have a
question like this is random because it
could go one way or the other houston
how much did your shirt cost you the
t-shirt yeah it just looks like a black
12 bucks 13 bucks yeah i mean that's
what i want okay
you never try not to wear like i love
really nice like suit coats like sport
coats like versace and really high-end
designer things but i don't want to like
this t-shirt is just such a bad
investment to buy a 500 version of this
yeah right because this is a brand i
don't need a brand to tell me that i'm
like cool or something right but i do
like the quality and like a really nice
suit jacket like what i wear to my grand
openings like those versace jackets have
gold in them and right they're very
unique and they're very special and and
they kind of accentuate my personality
right but like my jeans are 110 you know
they're guests or whatever they cost
like they're normal but like the shoes
is like a watch right where it's like an
accessory and you know every time i come
here i wear a different cool pair of
shoes and they're all so fancy yeah they
all got spikes on them yeah so how much
does your entire outfit cost well you're
going to count the watch well if you
count the watch it costs more than a
house but um i don't know i've got uh
like probably 130 worth of clothes on
and then a
i don't know essentially a 440 000 watch
kind of watches that it's uh
it's a rm um
yeah i mean this is a carbon once it's
not not the most expensive uh there's
rms that cost millions how much did you
pay for it this watch i paid uh
190 something one so it's like this
watch i believe was a sticker price of
like
i think it was 120 something and i paid
like 60 over sticker i'm on the waitlist
for like a good new one but they try to
give us like
rm gave me a allocation for a watch that
was like kind of like a dinky one and it
doesn't go up in value so i'd rather pay
60 over this watch was purchased before
the big boom now here's the thing why
because you're selling off some cars why
wouldn't you sell off the watch i only
have one i used to have 13
watches yes okay so i've kept one watch
that i just wear every day and i kept my
first watch i ever bought
so that one i don't wear it's just it's
a hublot it's like 30 grand and i
financed it on my credit card i was like
super stoked and you know it was like a
big moment for me to buy like a really
nice watch but i used to have a whole
bunch of watches and i just have one now
so whenever i like go out i i don't know
i'd like to have two one that's not just
like one black one and like one gold one
maybe that's like more luxurious but i
just wear this watch every day you know
and i mean it's a lot it's worth a lot
of value now but like i couldn't replace
it and i feel like i i just need one
watch and i think that's the key in any
any personal success you could have a
billion dollars and you're still gonna
wear the same clothes right i'm gonna be
the same way right i like to be slightly
pretentious with the cars and the shoes
and the watches but i'm like overkill
yeah where i'm like shopping at versace
every weekend with 40 000 right where
i'm trying to be someone i'm not i'm
trying to be a big guy i don't party i
don't drink so like i never want to be
surrounded by that level of like
you know
uh
insecurity that's what i call right and
so i don't know i think that's the key
to success in this city into any big
city is just be yourself
you know
i think that's good it's a good point to
end it on yourself
it's like breakfast time yeah i know you
know almost lunch exactly all right guys
so thank you so much for watching the
other thing you could do besides be
yourself is get a free stock down below
in the description subscribe sign up for
public.com
we'll be getting back to your messages
okay so make sure to message us there on
time so much alex for producing this
podcast man you're doing a great job
make sure to follow me on instagram
and thank you guys so much for watching
and until next time